i got to say i i think we're all
optimistic that we might be getting to
the end of this
pandemic soon and it's interesting
because it's going to yeah it's good
news
but think about this for the past year
everyone's had the perfect excuse for
not leaving their house or attending a
social
engagement and you know with the
pandemic that's going to go away
because i thought about that yesterday i
was like i don't have any excuses left
yeah yeah you know for a year now we've
been able to say
sorry there's a pandemic can't do that
anymore
you know you know friends are going to
start demanding
that you get together with them and
you're going to need
new excuses to stay home and wriggle out
of plans
things you don't want to do well guess
what
andy and i are here to save the day
we're going to share some excuses that
will still work
even when the pandemic is over for
example personally and you can write
these down
i like the old classic i have a headache
oh yeah
that's a good one i also like i have a
doctor's appointment yeah
yeah or here's a good one i'm getting my
wisdom teeth out
although if you've already used that one
you could go with maybe uh i threw my
back out taking off my mask
yeah or i ripped my ears off taking off
my mask
yeah uh i have to clean my gutters i
gotta take down the christmas tree
i gotta put up the christmas tree i
gotta get a pap smear i have to clean my
gutters
okay andy you said that already oh yeah
but see the first time i met masturbate
this time i'm actually gonna clean my
gutters
got it good night nice save yeah thank
you hey listen this one i'd love to but
it's young mc's birthday
i have my morning wine tasting i've got
to get a colonoscopy the next day and
i'll be drinking that weird fluid oh
yeah
i promised myself i'd learn more about
cryptocurrency
i'm having a sex talk with my kids
tonight and i have a lot of research to
do
you know i'd love to but i'm building
this shrink way in my attic
and then while i was at work my kids and
the neighbors kids accidentally shrunk
themselves
and from context clues i gleaned that
they were most likely swept into up into
a trash bag that we hauled to the
backyard
so my lady and i were going to build
this contraption and hover over the
grass and look for them with magnifying
glasses
gophers man oh i have to watch the big
game
uh andy you don't like sports you didn't
let me finish i have to watch the big
game migration across western wyoming
they have seven
kinds of deer i have to get my puppy
donna spade
wait wait a minute say that one again i
have to get my puppy donna spade
conan i asked you to dinner in january
last year and you know what you told me
what i say i'd love to but i have to get
my puppy donna spade what the hell man
i'm i'm sorry i must have been a little
confused let's keep going here's one
i can't my wife is in labor god damn it
what just yesterday i said hey we both
had the shot
let's get lunch outdoors and guess what
you said my wife's in labor
exactly why don't you want to eat with
me andy of course i want to eat with you
let's get lunch today after the show oh
actually i can't
why not i have to clean my gutters
that's a lie all right fine actually
conan the truth is i don't like to hang
out
outside of work and i just prefer to be
alone at home
you know what andy thank you
honesty it's refreshing
it's good to know
[Music]
i've got a good excuse we have to think
of a better ending for that sketch
i'd love to go with you however
this overlong sketch really needs
something to button it
yeah and that public service
announcement ending didn't work 10 years
ago and it doesn't work
that wheezing tired old [ __ ] of an
ending